well i had to stop that last
presentation because i ran out of time
but now we can
start up right where we left off so far
we had figured out the slope and it made
sense to us because we figured out that
the slope was -4 over 3 which means that
the rise
when when you can look at the two ways
when the run is three the rise is
negative four so let's see rise we went
down by negative four
and we ran three and you can keep doing
that on the line and you'll you'll keep
ending up on the line you could have
also gone down eight and then move it
over six or you can move over six and go
down eight if you went down eight you
would have showed up here and then you
would come down back here
see whatever the slope is as long as you
if you change the y by the rise and you
change the run by the x you should end
up on the line again i know i'm doing
this over and over again but uh i i
think it'll slowly sink in but anyway
where we left off we were going to solve
for b so that we could figure out the
final equation for this line
well just like we did the last time we
just have to substitute
a y or an x that we know works for this
line and we know either of these
coordinates will work and then we solve
for b so let's try this first one 2
comma negative 3.
so y is negative 3
don't get confused between x and y
y is negative 3 times
equals minus 4 over 3 times x which is 2
plus b
and then we get
negative 3 equals negative 8
over 3 plus b
and then we get b is equal to
well 3 is equal to minus 9 over 3
and then i'm just going to put this on
the other side so that's plus
eight over three so we get minus one
over three is the y-intercept
so the equation of this line is y is
equal to minus four-thirds x
and then this y-intercept is minus
one-third
so
i know this is extremely messy but the
equation of this line once again is y
equals minus four-thirds x minus
one-third now let's look at the graph
and see if that um if that makes sense
well let's see the y-intercept is right
here that's where you intersect the
y-axis at the point and we know we know
exactly what that point is it's 0
comma negative 1 3. that's that's the
y-intercept and it makes sense and even
when you look at an equation it's pretty
obvious this is going to be the
y-intercept because when x equals 0 this
term gets crossed out because
0 times negative 4 thirds and then y
would equal negative 1 3.
let's do one more
just to bore you
and because
my wife is a resident and she works 30
hours at a time and i have nothing
better to do
all right let me let me put that graph
back there
i joke but you don't realize it is true
okay
let's put the graph back there and i'm
going to do another
random points i'm going to go a little
faster this time so let's say i had
negative 8 comma 5
and i had
let me think of a good one
two
two comma
i'm just going to make up a number um
let's say
zero that's interesting two comma zero
so let's graph negative eight comma five
one two three four five six seven eight
one two three four five
right there is minus 8 comma 5
and then
1 2 and then 0 is right here so that's 2
comma 0 and now let me draw the line
oh my god i thought i was using the line
tool that's horrendous
i wish there was an undo tool
that was horrendous that was
unacceptable
that's a little bit better and i just
just so you know that the line doesn't
end there lines go on forever and every
in the coordinate axis
oh there you go okay so let's figure out
the slope of this line well change in y
over change in x
slope oh i'm using the line tool again i
must pass today
slope is
so let's take let's take this as a
starting point we'll get 5 over z 5
minus 0 y 1 minus y 2
over
x 1 minus 8 minus 2.
so it equals 5
over minus 10
and that equals minus one-half so that
means for every two we go over we go
down one right
well for every one we go down we go over
two which makes sense so if we go down
two
we'll go over four
right because two over four is the same
thing as one half hope that makes sense
to you i noticed this downward sloping
line so that was fast so we know that
the equation of the line so far is y is
equal to
minus one half x
plus
b now we just solve for b let's
substitute some
numbers in here well let's use this one
this is interesting two comma zero so y
is 0
equals minus 1 half times 2
plus b
well 0 is equal to this is minus 1 plus
b and we get b equals 1. so this is a
pretty easy problem
so now we get y
is equal to
minus one-half x plus one
okay now let's see if this actually
looks right on our problem well this is
telling us the y-intercept is at the
point 0 1
0 1 is right here and
our algebra confirms our drawing that
this is this is the y-intercept and when
we see that the slope is negative
one-half it makes sense because it's a
downward sloping line but it's not too
steep
for every
for every one that we go down we go over
two so that's negative one half
or you could say for every
two we move go we we run we rise
negative one either one we end up on the
line again
so i hope that helps i think you are
definitely ready to do um
a lot of these slope problems that we
have we have on the khan academy so i
hope you have fun and if you have any
questions you can attend one of the
seminars
have fun